There are two finer points that I
wanted to mention about Q-learning.
First is that the success of
Q-learning depends to some extent,
well, to a large extent on exploration.
So we need to explore as much of
the state and action space as possible.
One way to accomplish
this is with randomnes.
And the way we can interject that fairly
easily in the step of Q-learning,
where we are selecting an action,
we flip a coin and
randomly decide if we're going to
randomly choose an action.
So that means really
two flips of the coin.
The first is are we going to
choose a random action or
are we just going to pick the action
with the highest Q value?
Then if we decide okay, we're going to
choose an action randomly, now we need
to flip the coin again to choose which
of those actions we're going to select.
Typical way to implement this is
to set this probability at about
0.3 or
something at the beginning of learning.
And then over each iteration to slowly
make it smaller and smaller and
smaller until eventually we essentially
don't choose random actions at all.
What we gain here is when we're choosing
these random actions fairly frequently
is we're forcing
the system to explore and
try different actions
in different states.
And it also causes us to arrive at
different states that we might not
otherwise arrive at if we didn't
try those random actions.